foreign
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to Fandango's
exclusive interview with the cast of
Marvel Studios Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania my name is Eric Davis I am
so beyond thrilled to be here kicking
off the mcu's phase five in spectacular
fashion and joining me is this awesome
group of people the cast of quantumania
Welcome everyone thank you uh you know
first off Paul Evangeline congrats on
making it to the part three it's a big
deal yeah it was it was really exciting
to do I think we were all pretty
thrilled that we got to do another one
so and then to add these guys it was
really special yeah I mean Paul for you
personally coming this far in your
journey as a Marvel superhero and then
to arrive at this installment which
happens to be such a pivotal one in
Phase five I mean what is that what does
that mean for you you're dual Saga now
so you oh
it's a bit surreal and all honesty you
know the MCU is such an enormous thing
and has such a following globally just
to be a part of it in any way it can be
overwhelming and then to have now been
able to do this a few times and over the
course of several years is it it never
ceases to kind of blow my mind right on
Evangeline what kind of a part three
would you say this is I've heard it
described as really part one of phase
five I've heard it described as a family
road trip how would you kind of Define
this this adventure I would Define it as
a collision between the Ant-Man the WASP
franchises we've come to know and love
it and the greater Marvel franchise as
you know people have come to expect this
Grand epic scale from that franchise and
in ours it's just this beautiful
intimate character-driven family story
and and I love seeing those two worlds
collide together in this one film that's
awesome I want to get into your
characters and and where we we pick up
with them but first Catherine you know
the character of Cassie Lang is not
unfamiliar to MCU fans but this is the
first time we're going to see her suit
up as a hero alongside Ant-Man and the
wasp and this is your first time playing
her we all like a good MCU origin story
tell us about how you first found out
that you were going to be joining this
massive Marvel Cinematic Universe and
what that was like for you that moment
that moment I got a phone call I was I
got a phone call I was in my closet and
um they I talked to Peyton Reed our
super mega positron director and he told
me about Cassie Lang it was just a
meeting and he told me her whole journey
and the hero that she wants to be and I
was like this movie is going to be
awesome and it was awesome and so it's
an honor to play Cassie and I I think it
was like way better than I could have
imagined I was just telling Paul I'm
like every movie I do is going to be so
boring now it can't compare and to get
to to be in a movie where Kang the next
like villain she has no idea what she's
doing Cassie Lane has no idea what she's
doing she wants to be a hero and she's
face to face with the biggest super
villain of all time it's just she's
gonna learn some lessons Vegas super
villain of all time that is how I have
heard Kang the Conqueror described as
the most powerful villain that the MCU
has ever seen Mr Jonathan major sir let
me ask you this when you sign on to like
Kang that it involves multiple
variations of a character spanning
several years there is an Avengers movie
on the docket that's got his name in the
title so we know he's going to be around
for a while how how familiar with that
entire Journey are you up front do you
do you know his entire story all the way
through or do you get it more piecemeal
um I get it piecemeal you know
um
the initial call and explaining the
character there's so much promise in the
role you know there's so much promise in
the overarching company of the MCU
so that in and of itself is like okay
let's roll let's do this you know and
that's the promise I mean
these dual Saga members you know I knew
I was coming to join them I knew that I
know they're bringing in new classes you
know as as we're all watching
um so yeah I mean I get a piecemeal but
the promise of every day on set
um every scene you know there's a epic
promise of like you you you you're
kinging
it and so uh that's just that's just the
best I feel like we're going to see a
lot of kids uh in in Kang costumes
looking to conquer Halloween come
October have you had you had any like
really awesome fan experiences so far
uh just you know walking down the street
and someone say okay and you gotta look
up I go that's yeah what what's up you
know um that that that's all you know
it's it's uh it's early yet and
you know they gotta see the picture and
all that stuff but uh people are excited
you know I mean I guess when we were all
in um Brazil you know and and of course
the San Diego Comic-Con you know just
the iconography of him the the mythology
of him and we came out in in San Paulo
it was just nuts you know I mean it was
nuts uh Raging Raging so that was that
was great that's the MCU yeah you know
so let's talk about these characters
when when we kind of come into this
story
um uh you know Paul Evangeline uh where
where are Scott and hope I feel like
Scott's got a podcast he's got like a
book he's like employee of the century
you know him and hope are going to like
Galas they're all dressed up like are
they maybe milking this being in the
Avengers a little bit the celebrity of
it all a little bit where are these two
when we we pick up their story here I
don't know if we're really milking it I
mean certainly I mean I think I think
hope is has bigger fish to fry I mean
hope is certainly doing a lot of good
for the world and
using the company to try and you know
deal with some real real world issues I
think for me
it's not that I'm milking it but I'm
just I think my main concern which has
always been I think Scott's main concern
is being able to spend some time with
his daughter and connect Scott's missed
a lot of time over the last several
years but he does have to make a living
so why not write a book you know and it
might be milking it online yeah
tell us about Hope because you know I
feel like Hope Has Come and both of
these characters were coming in at a
high point really you know we've come
into Scott's life when he's really low
and and hope has has kind of reunited
with her father and her mother and so
where is Hope and and what does her
journey look like this time around well
she's a completely different person than
we when we first met her in the first
Ant-Man film at that time she was closed
she was cold she was very isolated she'd
had her heart broken at a very young age
and had just remained a bit of a
fortress ever since then and in the
journey that she's gone on in these
films she has really allowed the ice
around her heart to melt as she has
repaired her relationship with her
father as she has brought her mother
back from the quantum realm as she has
fallen in love and then also as she has
sort of Taken on this mantle of
stepmother to Cassie so now her life is
the polar opposite of where it was when
we first met her her life is full of
intimacy and relationship and she also
has all the success she ever dreamed of
and a super suit I mean nothing can
touch her at this point she's like on
top of the world and then the quantum
realm happens
Catherine who is Cassie when we pick up
with her in this film because it seems
at least based on the footage that we've
seen so far she's kind of gotten into
the family business a little bit she's
making some things maybe separate from
her family and and it seems like the
thing that she created or helped create
is what ultimately kicks this story into
high gear this is her fault yeah
I thought that she was doing the right
thing and it's all her fault she should
have listened to her dad but I think
deep down she kind of wants to be like
her dad even though she'll never admit
it and don't ask her because she'll
never say it's because of him but she's
falling in her dad's footsteps she wants
to be like him or at least she wants him
to be proud of her and you know he
believes in her and that's all it takes
is one person to believe in you and
she's really just a mess though tripping
impatient really funny
you know a dork she was not ready but
she thinks she is she's impatient I love
it not wants to be a hero but maybe not
ready not ready because she doesn't
understand what it means to be a hero
like she doesn't understand what it's
like to deal with a villain and like now
she's face to face with Kang and she's
gotten all the people she loves in
trouble she had no idea that was going
to happen and it did um Jonathan face to
face with Kang who is Kang when we when
we meet him in this film
well they come down to the quantum realm
you know
um
the quantum realm is my uh current
domain that's where I am you know and as
the title says I've conquered it
um
and so he's a man isolated
just there
um
working it out
I mean he is supposed to be the most
power powerful villain that the MCU has
ever seen where does that power come
from
uh where's that power come from well I
mean here's the thing with villains
right
um or with any character uh but
particularly with villains that uh yes
there is the manifestation of the power
but the the internal power is really the
drive you know and I think with King
something I've found so interesting is
that his pain and suffering and and this
discomfort and frustration with society
and the world and that is so great in
him that that friction has allowed him
to make himself
um into the super villain that you see
it is that internal friction that gives
him that power now how it manifests stay
tuned
but but yeah he he he his heartache is
um is great and I think is is
so massive he does live up to that
um
that title of being the you know biggest
baddest you know yeah MCU feeling that
beautiful that we've had the biggest bad
you know what uh I I this has been
described as a family road trip so I
thought it would be really funny to get
to know the quantum realm through like a
quick travel review so you know if they
they you know if you could just name
like one good really good thing or
really bad thing about the quantum realm
as if you were writing a travel review
for the next family that's going to road
trip through the quantum realm what
would you say well when you arrive you
have to drink some goo and then you can
get along and talk to people oh so you
have to drink something in order to kind
of just it's goo it's goo it's like red
goo I got the red goo you got the green
goo
I don't know let's see so there's some
gooey you get they get a beverage you
know we have 7-Eleven they have goo all
right so we got some goo as we arrive
and that I imagine that's maybe a
bad-ish kind of I think it tasted great
and then you can understand everybody
and they can understand you okay so
that's cool yes what about you Paul yeah
I think uh I would say you get to meet
some really interesting uh people you
get to meet some really interesting
things that might be people right
um and uh experience cultures uh
existed
food is great food is great the
restaurants
only we can take everybody to the
restaurants in the quantum Realm
my advice for The Travelers would be
sleep with one eye out
that's it keep keep your wits about you
because I can't tell you
about the quantum route
[Laughter]
Jonathan I there's a lot of circles we
see a lot of circles uh in the quantum
realm which I imagine may be a
manifestation of what time is circular
potentially that's what I think uh but
we'll see uh what would be your good or
bad review of the quantum Realm
good or very well I mean
both yeah yeah
uh if I would give any uh if my blog
would be um uh Pack Light
and you know uh a lot of people come
into Marvel movies and they're always
like I wonder how many like Easter eggs
or or cameos they're going to be
especially when we're in the Multiverse
and the quantum realm if you were to
give on the scale of one to ten where
maybe 10 is like it's gonna blow your
mind what do we say well for people that
are aware I think they're we have some
good ones in there some really good ones
um I'm obviously I'm not going to tell
you what they are but I think the
the ones that people find out about or
learn about Will
they would think would be a 10.
yo visually this film also looks
tremendous uh I I'm personally gonna go
see it in 3D it feels like that kind of
film
um you know maybe as audiences uh you
know this is the start of phase five
this is the start of something big
that's coming as audiences are maybe
walking out of this film I mean what do
you hope they're taken away from from
this installment Jonathan I can speak to
how I hope they uh feel you know I hope
they feel that um
the way I feel and the way I felt when
they said rap and they sent us all home
um fulfilled
emboldened excited you know really
excited for for what's uh for what's
coming you know extremely satisfied with
what they saw you know
um but excited for you know what these
Heroes and this villain
um have just uh has just done you know
and emboldened to you know see the next
picture in the next picture the next
picture and follow
um my MCU Heroes and and villains you
know for you know throughout this phase
and into the next well I personally
cannot wait to see this film I wish you
all the luck in the world on it thank
you so much for being here with us today
thank you for having us it was great
thank you we're good we're good